Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David
P. Here's an interesting voicemail about
the entire please define what a woman is
the thing, including my recent appearance on
the Michael Knowles Daily Wire Show. And this
is another aspect to this, which is why are
these people so obsessed with genitalia? Maybe
we should focus on that. Take a listen, David.
Speaker 6: I'm sorry, I'm not done your appearance
on the Michael. No show might really triggered me.
Um, just this idea that he's saying that women,
you know, the definition of women is the most
important thing in America. You have to push back
on that, make him feel like a pervert because he's
being a pervert. When he says that you got to say,
you really think whether or not a 13 year old has
a penis? You think what's inside of a pants of
10 is more important than potential nuclear
war? It's more important than North Korean
tests. How we respond to that. It's more important
to assessing our interventions overseas. And
do we send troops to Ukraine? What do we do
in Ukraine? Discussion of kids genitals is
more important to you and more interesting
to you, then foreign policy than domestic
tranquility than literally any other issue.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So it's an interesting idea,
which is to push back when when they do this
stuff. And say it's more applicable to the
bathroom stuff, I would say, than to like, you
know, the guitar, Angie Brown Jackson hearing,
maybe and just the general definition of
woman. But I think it's a fair thing to say.
Why are you so obsessed with the genitals of kids?
Nobody's paying attention to that. Are you saying
you would if you were in a bathroom with children?
It's it's a it's a rhetorical approach. I don't
think it's super substantive, but sometimes
you've got to win the rhetorical battle. So
I understand thinking about it. Very interesting.
Let me know what you think, but I have. It could
backfire if not done correctly. That would be the
concern. We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the new billionaire tax, not
millionaire billionaire tax proposed by Joe Biden.
We will talk about
Speaker 4: a new
Speaker 1: I don't know what to call it, a new
initiative from Uber. We're a New York City. All
New York taxis will be listed in the Uber app.
It's very interesting why this is happening.
And when Pat joins me, we're going to try to
figure out what happened yesterday at the Oscars,
where Will Smith slapped Chris Rock. And we have
some more information about it than we did now
at the start of the show. So we will talk about
that on today's bonus show. All of that and more.
And you can access it instantly by signing up
at Join Packman dot com. You can use the coupon
code. Wow. 22 to get a discount. We do depend on
the support of our viewers and listeners, so I
would love it if you signed up at joined Packman
dot com. And it comes with great perks like being
able to access the bonus show. You also get a
commercial free audio and video stream of the show
every day, six hours before it is published. And
so many other great perks, including a forthcoming
town hall, which I will tell you more about next
week. See you on the bonus show or otherwise.
Sadly, if you're not a member, we'll have
to wait until tomorrow to be together again.